are these whistleblowers heroes
i think the different word for me is
necessary
okay i i don't know if i
feel comfortable saying heroes
or not there may be i mean for somebody
that's exposing this stuff they're
sitting there saying they are heroes
uh but i it's very easy in a situation
like this to blame everything on zuck
and dorsey it's very easy to do that for
us oh it's all zuckers zuckerberg
zuckerberg that's only that's what it is
okay yeah fine yeah there's some
responsibility on the guy at the top
which is what everything rises and falls
on leadership fine yes got it
and then there's some responsibility on
the
leadership team that knows about this
what they're doing about it my only
concern is if this thing gets to the
government if the government controls
that button
you don't want that no i can guarantee
you don't want that look an insurance
company that we're doing business with
back in the days
aviva i don't know if you remember aviva
or not back in 2007 2006 they were the
number one insurance company for this
product called the iul they were killing
it with annuities and life i never hear
about aviva anymore yeah because they
were bought out it's a different company
which by the way let's stick to aviva
and and uh
one day
everybody gets a call and says hey have
you noticed they're no longer taking as
many policies as they were now this is
people that told me i never did business
with the people but this is like 50
people told me this
i said no why what happened he says it
seems like
you know they're no longer taking
underwriting like they did because they
used to i submit 50 clients like this
they accepted all 50 of them but the
last 10 clients i submitted like this
they're no longer taking it what the
hell is going on here
so then from the outside ward got out
that they control the knob and the knob
is underwriting underwriting is we will
take a client at this level and we will
not take a client at this level so you
just simply control the knob but in
insurance you make money when you no
longer take premium meaning it takes
seven years for an insurance policy to
be profitable to the insurance carrier
so it's not a short-term plan it's a
long long term the number you hear about
is typically seven years okay
so if they have to control the knob and
say oh here's where we're going to go
great i don't mind if aviva has that
knob to control
i worry if the government controls that
knob because aviva controls that knob
guess what there's 50 other insurance
companies i can go to yeah it's going to
be disruptive yeah it's going to be
annoying yeah you know i can't believe
you did this yeah and they did some
stuff that was very shady but they
controlled enough we went to another
insurance company you can go i'm going
to go to this insurance company great
and we interviewed with them we went to
a different insurance company and the
guys that were there at that time they
said yep who left to another company
said that actually happened that's what
we were going through so i i would still
much rather keep this on facebook than
put this on the government because all
it takes is one guy to come in and he
knows like what you talk about with what
obama did with irs
one guy to come in forget about it
forget about it yes forget about it so
think about it right now we're talking
all of a sudden starts doing the
spinning thing and the video is not
going and boom podcast taken down you
can't have this tons of types of
conversation
how many people today this thing's gonna
end up getting say 80 000 views let's
just say give or take 80 000 100 000
just this podcast the short clips say
gets a million views okay total this
thing gets one and a half million views
total with short clips
how many people you think you shifted
their mindset
how many people do you actually think
added a million and a half you got them
to think and go home and talk to their
husband their wives their kids their
friends their peers their co-workers how
many people have their mindset been
shifted by listening to this podcast
it's just one that's working shifted you
mean shifted no it shifted like to the
point where you know i got to tell you i
was listening to podcasts today and the
guys were talking about the saying you
know this will filter it i don't know
yeah but this guy's seventh oh no i know
who he is okay and they were talking
with this other guy named jordan and
adam said this and they were saying this
and i got to tell you i'm wondering what
do you guys think about this because so
then it's like you know what i'm having
a hard time believing this now and then
that conversation goes to one person two
three four five eight fifty hundred two
hundred
that's shifting mindset you're getting
people to start questioning certain
things how many people out of the
million and a half you think are
thinking right now and they're shifting
their mindsets being shifted what do you
think what do you think that number is
actually what you think about this
kai what do you think that number is
1500
1500 okay what do you think that number
is he you want like point zero one
percent top of a deal yeah whatever
you're gonna set the over under at i'm
taking the under okay so you're going to
say less than one percent whatever
you're going to set the over under is
i'm taking the under okay so can you
instead of being so technical gambler
from vegas give us a number one percent
half a percent i i well if there's any
indication of whether it's going on our
country we we use these stats all the
time that you know 45 percent of people
are going to vote democrat 43 are going
to percent uh vote republican
three percent are going to pull
libertarian and then there's maybe 10
percent maybe you're right that are
changing you're right okay so what
percent so ten percent if that great i'm
going to go lower let's just say
let's say 10 000 people let's say a
thousand to ten thousand people say
single digits let's say it's a thousand
people say it's a thousand people you
know what thousand people leads to a
thousand leads to ten thousand two
hundred thousand very quickly it's
conversations you had that leads to dot
dot dot dot but imagine if you can't
have those conversations anymore
so that's why i don't want that button
to be controlled by the government i
just don't i you know that's a that's a
great point and to be honest you know i
really don't even care about changing
people's minds i just want them to start
questioning what they there we go being
told i want them to i just shifting
mindsets not changing minds but just
having my mind just do it yeah just
question like you know what just be
inquisitive you know david david you
you're over there you're awake bro
when when you i'm listening when you
first came in right when you for you
you're a little younger you're in a
demographic
i'm sure that you had uh a mentality or
or i'm sure that you had an opinion of
you know capitalist or whatever before
you came here and now six months later
has that opinion changed at all yeah
absolutely i think i had like a vague
understanding of everything um just kind
of what you see online but now obviously
being more immersed than seeing you guys
discuss it day to day definitely changed
my opinion on a lot of things and i see
things through a different sort of um
glass i think just humanizing different
perspectives is the most important thing
like we we are more
and more and more we're driven and maybe
it's because like with what she said on
60 minutes facebook is trying to do this
you know these people are libtards these
people are idiots these people are
maggots these people right and it's
humanizing somebody with a different
perspective is an incredibly important
thing because we we are so much more
alike than we are different all right
even even me and you cami me and you are
so much more alike than we are different
right
but
you know he's talking to kamala harris
gerard just stepped out of his comfort
zone she's staring at me she's looking
right at me but dude she's giving that
little again
i just i hate how manipulated we are in
this moment i hate feeling manipulated
and i hope other people are recognizing
that manipulation they don't have to
agree they can disagree but i want them
to recognize the manipulation that
that's my goal more than anything else
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]